Rambo dead and what fate did Marvel
really intend for Loki here are some of
the biggest changes ever made to movies
after a test screening Fatal Attraction
remains one of the most successful
Thrillers of the 1980s a film that
launched Glenn Close into stardom and
earns six Academy Award nominations the
film is still a memorable 10
psychological Thrill Ride thanks to the
incredible lead performances of close
and Michael Douglas but according to
close it was actually originally going
to end in an even darker way than It
ultimately did remember the scene in
which Dan goes to Alex's apartments and
they fight over a kitchen knife well
Alex was supposed to use that moment to
get Dan's Prince on the knife which she
would then kill herself with and used to
frame him for her murder test audiences
had something else in mind close told
movie line the original ending was a
gorgeous piece of film Noir she kills
herself but makes sure that his prints
are all over the knife and he gets
arrested he knows he didn't do it but
he's going to jail anyway but audiences
wanted some kind of cathartic ending so
he went back months later and shot the
ending thus in the movie now a different
ending in which Dan and his wife Beth
fight Alex until Beth shooter was added
test screenings can sway many different
aspects of a film's plus but it's not
often that you hear about a film that
comes out of the test reading process
with a different title that's exactly
what happened to the last James Bond
film of the 1980s and Timothy Dalton's
second and final outings Bond Licensed
to Kill the film was originally titled
licensed revoked because that's exactly
what happens in the film Bond becomes a
rogue agent as he goes on a quest for
vengeance against a drug kingpin who
killed his friend's wife shortly after
their winning and M suspends him and
revokes his trademark license to Kill
however when the film was test screened
for American audiences they were puzzled
by the title because they thought of
license for votes as something that
happens to drivers licenses that's a
cool secret agent says license to Kill
so the title was altered to avoid any
confusion you could have had everything
why
Scott Pilgrim reverse is a world in its
source material you're the Scott Pilgrim
graphic novel series by Brian Lee
O'Malley developed simultaneously
without Manny releasing the final volume
of his story just weeks before Edgar
Wright's film at theaters that man's
writing company did not necessarily have
a concrete ending from The Source
material to go by when they wrote the
film and that meant an ending that
created some trouble that tests
screenings the original ending of the
film featured Scott's staying with nice
Chow his girlfriend in the beginning of
the film rather than being with Ramona
Flowers but according to Wright this
created arguments during the testing
process right side Entertainment Weekly
the way that we'd originally written it
which wasn't quite right is we were
trying to do a graduate or Heartbreak
Kid style ending to tell the honest
truth Ellen wongu plays knives was so
lovely and so Charming that it just made
me feel horrible even doing that ending
so the ending we did have was neither
here nor there when the test screenings
didn't go well Wright O'Malley and
co-writer Michael Bacall went back and
wrote a new ending in which knives
encourages Scott to be with Ramona I'm
too cool for you anyway
a 1980s team rom-com classic written by
John Hughes and directed by Howard
Deutsch Pretty in Pink is an interesting
case of test screening changes in part
because you can still experience the
original version of the story if you're
willing to track down the novelization
of the film The Book you see was already
written by the time the studio requested
a new ending from Hughes and Deutsch
following a test reading response in
which audiences clearly picked a winner
in the battle for Andy's heart in the
film's original ending Andy actually did
come around to falling for her longtime
best friend ducky who'd been in love
with her the whole time but Tess
audiences wanted Andy to end up with
Blaine the upper class guy because the
novelization is based on the original
script ducky still gets the girl in the
book but Hughes and Deutsch crafted a
new ending in which Blaine apologizes to
Andy and ducky feeling they should be
together and ducky vouchers for him okay
you're right
he's not like the others
so if you like that Andy ended up with
Blaine you have early test audiences to
thank
Neil Marshall's brutal Subterranean
horror flick The Descent is a film that
changed not so much because of
traditional test audiences but because
of the tests that wasn't released in the
UK which happened more than a year
before the film finally made its way to
the states The Descent has a Relentless
grimy Thrill Ride full of Gore and
creature Thrills and it's UK ending
drove its sense of dread and darkness
all the way through to the final moments
as the film ends with a reveal that
Sarah the last survivor of the cave only
dreamed that she'd escaped and was in
reality still sitting in the dark
imagining her dead daughter sitting
across from her by the time the US
release was looming audiences are given
feedback saying they found the ending
too Bleak and distributed Lionsgate as
for a change so Marshall cut the final
minutes of the film allowing Sarah to
escape the cave for real
it might be hard to believe now but
first blood was originally supposed to
be a one and done affair because John
Rambo was originally supposed to die yes
Sylvester Stallone's tortured Vietnam
veteran who became synonymous with
action movie juggernauts in the 1980s
was originally going to get killed at
the end of his first and only movie but
that's what happens in David Morrell's
novel on which the film is based it's
also what happened in the first version
of Ted koschev's film which he saw as a
suicide mission that would end with
Rambo killing himself from the moment he
joined the production Stallone felt the
suicide ending for Rambo was too
excessive and pushed an alternate ending
that car Chef ultimately shot on the
same day as his original Ending by the
time the film ended up with Orion
pictures the distributor had the idea to
run a test screening with the original
ending just to see what would happen
carchef told Entertainment Weekly the
test audience were all unanimous they
all said in different words this is the
best action film I've ever seen But the
ending is horrible
roll the ball sounds like the kind of
film that might work well now director
John mctinian who helped give birth to
the action movie As We Know It sets out
to remake a cold classic from director
Norman jewison about an ultra brutal
futuristic sport her world will be
watching because this is your year the
2001 remake of rollerball seemed to be
in trouble from the beginning but
mctiernan Drew internet if opting to
change a futuristic setting of the
original film and ditching the first
script then came test screenings in the
spring of 2001. the response was
terrible thanks in no small part to an
extremely negative review from ancient
core news and the studio went into
damage control mode the release date was
pushed to 2002 when tianin conducted two
weeks of reshoots to refine certain
scenes and the studio mandated that the
film be cut to make a PG-13 rating
hoping younger audiences would respond
to it this meant all of the nudity in a
good deal of the violence were toned
down rollerball was ultimately a
critical and Commercial failure
sometimes test audiences are extremely
specific with what they want this was
the case with The Lovely Bones Peter
Jackson's 2009 adaptation of Alice
cball's best-selling novel Jackson told
Reuters that test audiences had a lot to
say about one of the film's key ending
points the specific complaint was
regarding the death of the child killer
Mr Harvey who was killed as he is in
seat belt's novel when an icicle hits
him on the shoulder and causes him to
fall down into a ravine audiences were
happy to see Harvey die but they felt
his death was too quick so Jackson went
back to The Cutting Room and added more
suffering in the final film we see
Harvey's full fall to his death complete
with bone crushing bouncers and facial
lacerations
it's now considered one of Martin's
course says he's best but members of the
original test screening audience for
Goodfellas walked out and disgust the
reactions were instant and visceral with
several people leaving in the opening
moments of the film as Tommy DeVito
violently stabs Billy bats to death
Studio Executives were rattled speaking
with Entertainment Weekly in 2019 scores
said he reflected on the test screening
process saying I'm in the process of
making the film I screen it for some
people there you go maybe you don't need
that and maybe I do things or maybe not
following the Goodfellas screening Score
says he began tweaking the movie's edit
working directly with editor Thelma
schoon marker the two determine
precisely how many stub wounds the bat's
character could sustain on film before
it became gratuitous not all screening
comic cards resulted in cuts to the film
however scores says he revealed that
while the violence was too much for
viewers a love Score says he's real-life
mother and the role of business DeVito
Tommy's mother their feedback saved the
heartwarming sequence from The Cutting
Room floor and the final result is one
of the greatest gangster movies of all
time that's it and I put that in the
morning I'm free I love you
command the legend of
Ronnie has become a modern comedy
classic but the original plot was
received so poorly by test audiences
that it had to be completely re-shot the
retolding left several big name comic
actors on The Cutting Room floor like
Maya Rudolph Steven root Amy Poehler and
Justin Long there was even a role for
rap Legend Chuck D that had to be
abandoned we all feral super fans need
not fret however I saw the unused
footage from the feature film mostly
involving a terrorist group called The
Alarm Clock Was repurposed into a
so-called lost film called wake up Ron
Burgundy initially released as Zone
director DVD feature it's now included
as an extra on the unrated Rich mahogany
edition Blu-ray the theatrical release
of course became a huge hit Anchorman
earned over 90 million dollars at the
box office and has a rating of 86 with
audiences on Rotten Tomatoes but beyond
the numbers it became what a titular
character is known as a legend if you
want to throw down in fisticuffs fine
I've got Jack Johnson and Tom O'Leary
waiting for you right here thought maybe
the star of his own series of movies in
the MCU but Loki is just as beloved in
fact Loki is easily the most popular
villain slash anti-hero of the
Multiverse with a Redemption Arc and
Thor Ragnarok and his own extremely
popular series on Disney plus imagine
then if Loki had truly died at the end
of Thor the Dark World as originally
intended Tom Hiddleston revealed on the
Empire film podcast the Loki's death and
Thor the Dark World was meant to stick
but that test screening audiences
rejected the idea naturally it makes
sense that fans wouldn't trust any Loki
death scene as a notorious trickster
character is known for his misleading
Illusions indeed moments earlier in Thor
the Dark World the character makes it
look like he cuts off his brother's hand
in a moments of betrayal plus Loki's no
stranger to faking his death as he does
at the end of the first store it's
therefore fitting that the sly adopted
as guardian pulls another fast one
Loki's a dark World death was meant to
serve as a Redemption Arc for the
mischievous villain while it can be said
that undermining that intention in the
Dark World leaves the middle of the film
with no real Stakes It ultimately allows
Loki to serve a much greater purpose and
enjoy a much more satisfying redemption
in Thor Ragnarok and Beyond
foreign
[Music]